you're welcome to this video playing
fritz come from the US and people liked
my recent try with the Kings gambit so
i'm i'm repeating that okay did I do
something wrong here hmm possible yeah
it's this for vehicle to gambit again
dumb I have no idea last time I played
huh okay so shouldn't check this be good
right now oh yeah okay it's not it's not
it's not clear at all
yeah I thought rook everyone but of
course if he takes on d3 my pawn
structure it's a complete wreck there
are some alternative the check is not
really helping ok BF at least he has got
the King the king in the middle that's
some alternative here let's say I play a
crazy move like before this is something
ok we'll take here anyway I'd like to
look at one at such lame move before
text takes bishop tags yeah but it's up
before I sweetie it's just losing a pawn
ok let's go look at one check it's not
bad I mean it's just not the most
dynamic way to play um ok this is
hanging
yeah default move I'd like to plan
yeah I know it looks very ugly but I
want the King on c2 if possible oh this
is a dynamic way to play Jack okay first
get this get this plate
yeah it's not not too great
but I need to get get this exchange this
Bishop see one maybe on a three or
something on III if I get this dis
exchanged it's not turn not bad
takes before would be one and this
activates pieces at least if it takes
e.m you cannot take twice on c3 and t5
because of Bishop e3 this is very good
and gap at least I got my book activated
now the the issue of course is also the
time I spent ages deciding on that
yeah I watched like to maybe night a six
or something not bad or a 5 a 9 a-6
looks like decent
maybe you can actually say Jack t5 okay
at this I don't know this looks to me
like it's helping something white Bishop
e3 checkers some move
and beasts Avila saying this is I think
this was a mistake allowing allowing
that so let's check at the check-in and
now this okay but this really yeah I
cannot believe in Bishop see ATM it's so
passive now
trying to play on the week back right
here note that it's close to a mate text
x rupee 8 made threatened
no rookie is seven threatening should be
eight
mmm yeah very active position now
probably this is good for wide yeah okay
but I can go here how do you develop a
96 as a check this is stupid check ah ok
and I take a phone we can take a default
your take is that ok I can i still have
fun good compensation but not enough to
turn to win problem check
yeah I'm active enough to to not lose
the game but no chances to to win
not not quite sure what he's doing but
okay it's it's a draw in any case
yeah my suspicion is he just wants to
check in on time does it really look for
any any news
ya know he gives me some more headway
than then I will win this check possible
time Jane
and I don't really have a winning idea
check now this is a winning idea black
resides yeah right sometimes happens if
you don't pay any attention to the
actual position and just want to win on
time by playing random moves yeah okay I
should never win the game of course it's
at the beginning of the end game black
had an extra porn but he had very little
chances to do something of course he
could have tried i mean this is this is
protecting itself and if he plays f6
king f7 h5 black has some chances it's
it's an extra porn but ok if you just
play random moves to win on time you do
and sometimes lose the game what
interests me is how I could have
actually wanted because here I'm
blackest of course totally outplayed
it's a it it's almost stem waited here
now I probably should just take yeah I
should just take I overlooked at 96 as a
check of course yeah this is quite nice
okay in figures here I have this this
idea it's additional idea or here also
yeah this is nice very active active
pieces
the ID it got very a very passive now
the problem was special takes you three
inches which is I think just a mistake
in P must play this one yeah this is
also given us as a pretty as some
substantial edge for black by the comp
but this is this is a mistake it just
activates me this Hanks Bishop a three
yeah here black needs to be cautious
computer wants to go here check and play
like that with the quality gap this is a
line where I get to get something get
the porn back and at the end it will
probably be drawn like this okay thanks
for watching